screen Black Adam earlier this week I
want to get some quick thoughts on it
start off with Black Adam himself The
Rock now I was really impressed what
Dwayne Johnson was able to do here he
was able to bring a very stoic but
passionate very driven performance but
one that made you lean in to the
performance as opposed to leaning out
and just observing like a lot of other
superhero Fair he authentically captured
the spirit of an anti-hero brings me to
Hawkman now this is one of my favorite
DC characters in Aldous Hodge absolutely
crushed I want to see franchises around
this guy he played such a hero and I
love that I felt for both his point of
view as well as Black Adams Pierce
Brosnan was absolutely born to play Dr
Fate another of my favorite DC
characters done very well here wish we'd
gotten a bit more time with quintessa
swindella cyclone and Noah centineo has
a blast with that animated mask it's a
very fun playful energetic performance
overall very impressed what they were
able to do with the politics of an
anti-hero and living a world with Heroes
the giant third Act of a film which is
its greatest strength and weakness but
it is a more than worthy inclusion in
the dceu